weaker part of the case too so you
mentioned CCTV footage of what right so
CCTV footage of so CCTV footage is the
imperative it basically shows what it'll
give us a very good window into
understanding where these women detained
were they controlled were they let out
it won't give us the full scope but
it'll give us a significant score both
inside and outside they have the CCTV
they also had CCTV in the house where
the girls were living none of that has
been included
so they didn't they didn't include the
CCTV footage that was actually in the
house when the girls were living there
that's right and so and the defense
wants to include it and that's gonna I'm
gonna explain why that
violets on other articles within
international law which is then
incorporated into Romania law I don't
think they have to I don't think there's
an obligation for the court to include
every single piece of evidence it's
international law no hold on sorry to
include every single piece of evidence
that we would want the defense to
include right at some point
um I'm pretty sure that their goal is to
just balance out whether or not a future
investigation is likely to lead to some
sort of criminal charge it's not to
present the entirety of the defense's
case at that point in time to see if
they can dismiss the charges it's just
to see if there's enough to detain them
there for the investigation to continue
meaning they're going to begin to or
they're already in the process of
subpoenaing electronic records and
devices and going through chat logs and
everything and the judge and so far as
the statements he's released has felt
like there are uh significant enough
claims and I think publicly I think we
can all see that that it warrants
detaining them especially given that
their Flight Risk so that the
investigation can conclude and it might
be at the end of that investigation to
decide well there's nothing going on
here and then they release them but it I
mean I think right now what we've seen
publicly is we've all seen this plenty
enough evidence out there to say it's
probably something here that's worth
investigating that that's not correct
because the reason why they have this
process is because you can give someone
who's been accused of a crime due
process he's given an opportunity to
present the evidence and then the CPS
makes the decision the reason for that
is because everybody knows if you have a
scenario in any kind of system where the
prosecutor only provides positive
evidence to try and prosecute and he
doesn't provide the evidence that
weakens his case you will end up in
trial no matter what and then what will
happen is everybody knows even if your
innocent trial risk could go wrong and
you could go to jail hence why they have
these uh things in place to ensure that
doesn't happen and innocent and more
innocent people aren't incarcerated and
someone and I know you're from the
United States where there's a huge
amount of incarcerations and more than
anyone per capita around the world as
well as for example in the United States
you have much more black people Hispanic
people 300 more who have been
incarcerated so again this is an example
of another black man who's basically
being incarcerated in sorry left do you
not agree I don't know I don't think
this has anything to do with black men
or whatever or whatever that's being
incarcerated I don't know why that's
even I don't know it does it does
because basically you're ignoring the
fact that he's in Eastern Europe it's a
basically significantly has a
significant amount of issues in terms of
race issues it also has a significant
amount of issues in terms of sex
trafficking yeah well it has well and we
will talk about that but in terms of the
significant areas issues significant
amount of islamophobia you have a
scenario where this country has not
allowed
um any kind of dark dark immigrants into
their country but now they've changed
that for Ukrainian immigrants and
allowed a significant amount in you've
got significant amount history of
islamophobia so of course when a man
when a black man who is a Muslim gets
incarcerated immediately after he's
converted Islam and I think as long as
the investigation been going on well
since April well well they claim that
investigation has been gone for April we
don't know exactly it's gonna be
interesting to see when the evidence
comes out what evidence comes out but
what we do know is
he was do it just capacity is there a
single shred of evidence to point to
anybody at any point of this process
being either as racist or islamophobic
I've just explained to you examples of
how Romania Romania has demonstrated
that and also I'm going to demonstrate
to you throughout this process how for
example people are not understanding
that a lot of the comments he makes is
based on his Heritage is based on his
background where he comes from something
which I understand you may not
understand based on your upbringing and
you know being a white man you know let
me ask that yeah let me ask that one
more time is there a single shred of
evidence that anybody has participated
in any islamophobia or racism yeah yeah
no no I've just giving you an example of
Romania being having a significant
amount of uh of of racism well I think
it'll be harsh color racism but it's a
significant indicator if you're not
letting people who have of dark dark
color into your country but you're
letting people of white color into your
country I think that says a lot okay so
I'll ask a third time and if you don't
have an answer that's fine you have
nowhere no no any islamophobia or racist
no no president I've just giving you
evidence I've just giving you telling me
that the country as a whole maybe have
had problems with racism but in this
particular case I'm curious if there's
any like in the United States if
something happens and a cop was racist
we might look for like a statement that
the cop has made you wouldn't just say
that like wow a black guy got arrested
that's racism right but you're saying
that no no no I'm not because he got
arrested it's racism and islamophobia so
I'm curious if there's any evidence of
that whatsoever no no what I'm saying is
when you look at the scenario there is
the significant issues when it comes to
the fact that he is uh he is a black man
and he is a just convert to Islam and
even incarcerate in a Eastern European
country to ignore that is ridiculous and
I'll explain why because human again
this is a scenario where if you ignore
the issues of race if you ignore the
issues of someone's Heritage which has
happened a lot in this case because I
know and we're going to talk about some
of the videos that you're complaining
about then you can basically break it
into the Bare Bones and look at
literalism and convict anyone of
anything but it's illogical you have to
look at the background you have to look
at the history of the person in in
reality when when you take all them
things into consideration they have a
significant impact look this is quite
simple and because you can give these
examples and obviously you have to
generalize them this is a scenario where
let's be clear it's a person who's the
black man who's being again accused of
doing accused of rape of human
trafficking on essentially white women
um and being incarcerated in an Eastern
European country without enough evidence
I mean that takes me back according to
says here that takes me back to you know
for example the United States and you
know in you know when these type of
things will happen in the plantation
basically you have a significant issue
where black people are being accused of
rare by white people and it's happened
significantly throughout the West you've
seen it now with Benjamin Mendy you sort
of
um Greenwood footballers who were
accused and now after losing so many
years of their life they've finally been
let out so they think that this is not
happening subconsciously or consciously
is is an issue okay so just this is a
personal feeling that I have I think
that when we pivot to other cases I feel
like it's because we know that this case
is very weak if you want to talk about
racism that exists the United States or
racism that exists in particular cases
um I'm free to do that at any point in
time but right now we're talking
specifically about the Undertake case
Andrew Tate is a man that has released
an entire University guide on how to be
a pimp on how to seduce women and get
them to work for you and how to sex
traffic on how to scam them on taxes is
on how to do all of these things he's
had charges in multiple countries
relating to rape he's had charges in
Romania now relating to his entire
business relating to sex trafficking to
try to hand wave all of this and go
islamophobia and racism would be okay if
we had even one iota of evidence a
statement that a prosecutor made a
statement that a judge has made uh any
any type of evidence but right now we
don't have okay any of that so I can
only go by what I've seen in front of
him so then based on that based on that
then you deny institutionalism because
you can never have a scenario where you
can have use specific evidence for
generalization but the whole point is we
use generalization to we should we
should we show many examples to then say
look this is a general issue
that's fine but we use generalization to
talk about General issues we don't use
generalization talk about it no no no
you not at all what happens is you you
use specific issues to create a
generalization and then said
generalization is used for subsequent
issues that's actually how it works in
terms of
um coming back to the point because you
made up quite a lot of points in terms
of the allegations again because this is
another problem what we have and because
we're on the racial let's talk about it
so you have a scenario where you've
basically got a guy who comes from Luton
England who's basically got a background
in
look he was basically if you give a
American comparable he's basically from
the ghetto he has a scenario where
people from that that kind of upbringing
are talking in very much slang humor
ghetto type talk I'm a Gangster Emoji I
did this I did that that girl that this
that all that kind of stuff so that's
how they talk then to say oh guess what
he's talked like that therefore he must
have done these things he's calling
women like this he's he's saying that
he's done this he's done he said he's
done fraud all of these things are huge
hugely problematic in the sense of
you're basically
removing his history and Heritage now I
understand as a white man you may not
understand the background of Heritage
and these type of things that he's going
through but the issue is that's quite
important
do you not agree no
um why not because me being white or
black or whatever has nothing to do with
him giving a deta I don't now I'm gonna
be honest okay I've only been in London
a few times okay now I haven't walked to
some of the roughest Parts but I haven't
maybe there are parts we walk around and
they're talking about how the top G's do
tax fraud on their employees maybe
that's just a way of speaking but if it
is a way of speaking and you detail it
it like to an incredible level and you
have a business where you claim to do
that and you put that out on videos on
social media and then you go to jail for
it yeah you're probably gonna get in
trouble um
let me finish responding okay your
entire point that this is just a way of
talking is ridiculous it is absurd he is
listed exactly a step-by-step guide on
how he lover boys girls into his sex
trafficking business he uses actual
prostitution terms like bottom [__] to
describe his relationship to some of the
employees that he has he talks about
bringing women into his into his company
to work them as sex traffic models and
then he specifically talked about
defrauding them using taxes to steal
money from them I don't think that I
think it's a little bit racist of you to
say that that's just how people from
ludin England or whatever talk or that's
how they function I don't believe that
is the case okay so I'll answer your
question so no again your point is
actually doesn't make sense and it
doesn't follow it's not secretary and
I'll explain why the reason is because
when you look at what he said online
again you could give the example a
bottom [__] and so on so forth that's
how that that's basically slang that's
how people talk and that's what you're
not understanding in terms of let's look
at your example which is completely
ridiculous because what you're saying is
guess what he said this online therefore
he should be convicted based on it
online well that's the influence you're
making basically online you give this
example you said he's trying to defraud
them because online what he actually
said was this in that video because I
know the video you're referring to he
says in the same video he says oh I'm
gonna take all the money in the same
video he says I'm gonna give 50 50. in
the same video he says I'm gonna give 50
30 70 30 because you know 20 you know
I'm gonna tell us for
um tax purposes but then I ain't gonna
pay the taxes and hence why you're
making the claim for fraud the point is
this from the court documents which I'm
sure you've read he it's none of that is
in there in the court documents what it
actually says is complete opposite what
it says is and this is the worst one so
this is the worst woman she says
I received 50 he receives 25 so she
receives double of what she received
what he receives so that is nothing got
to do with uh has no links to the video
so what you're what and and she doesn't
mention anything about being defrauded
of taxes because she's receiving the
full 50 she's receiving 50 percent
so what you're claiming is guess what I
don't care about what he's what the
court documents say I don't care what
the witness is saying but guess what in
the video he said this and therefore he
should be convicted or based on the
video no there's only two explanations
for the video because the court
documents don't add up to what the video
says either he was exaggerating and
talking in this kind of slang language
is what I'm trying to explain so he was
exaggerating and or it could be which is
a possibility that it was so long ago
that he did engage in those practices
and no longer does but what we know is
in this case what he is being a charge
for so what sorry what he's being held
for he doesn't be charged yet so what
he's been arrested for no one says that
okay I so I'm sure you've talked to a
lot of people that have only watched
clips of Andrew Tate which is fair and I
think that a lot of people say a lot of
dumb things about him because they've
only seen Clips which is also not fair I
think people shouldn't do that
um but I think you're relying on me
having only seen Clips So you you're
trying to pass this off as slang when he
used that phrase bottom [__] he wasn't
passing it off his slang he was very
specifically detailing bringing girls
that were in love with him over to
dinner where he would introduce them to
his youngest youngest working or one of
his younger working models a woman that
he met at 16 that had been working with
him for five years is now 21 and how he
would use her to mislead the
relationship that they had so that she
could get the girl the new one that was
brought in into working as a as a cam
girl this is prostitute Behavior this is
pimping Behavior this is exactly what it
is when he says bottom [__] here he's
not just using slang in a funny way to
talk about a girl that's a friend of his
that also works with her girlfriend he's
literally detailing step by step the
process by how he would deceive and
mislead which are key components of sex
trafficking a new woman that he's
brought in with another woman he would
mislead the extent of their relationship
and then he would use that to get her to
go and be a camp girl so that that is
not slang right right let me finish
that's right you just talk for ages
yeah this you just I just spent like
half the time
I go non-stop okay so it's not a slang
thing secondly you're bringing up this
thing that the witness says they got 50
that is not what the witness said the
witness said that originally there might
have been an agreement where it was a
50-25-25 split but the witness also said
that they were randomly dinged for
different charges that made it so they
didn't get that payout for instance if
you didn't stream the full 12 hours you
might be fined like one thousand to four
thousand uh whatever the Roman um
or whatever the Romanian currency is and
that there were a lot of things where
because one of the claims was they had
to work 12-hour shifts with a five
minute break and if they didn't work
enough there the witness also said that
if they didn't post enough on only fans
they didn't post enough tickets that
they also were doing their pay as well
so while on paper it might have been a
50 50 split we have the issues where the
witness is saying that they've lost some
of it due to being fined and we also
have the fact that Andrew Tate on video
has talked about how to defraud the
women with their taxes and we have
another statement of him saying that he
also oftentimes just builds in
cryptocurrency which is impossible to
track the women would have no idea if
she's getting that or not
right so again you're put your Arc your
this statement that you've related is
inaccurate so the woman who said that 50
25 25 she did she did another way we
could pull this up on screen the
document that you guys are talking about
do you know what it's called it's on
some website spice something it's in
Romanian
yeah you didn't bring a Romanian
translator are you even trying I thought
it was a serious show Dad
Jesus uh so how did you read it then the
document you got it someone translated
it and then oh okay but I don't know
about that Romanian you learned Romania
I have Romanian friends you can also use
a Google translate on this other thing
too yeah
I'll pull it down okay because we could
also pull up the video you guys were
talking about too so so in terms of what
you're saying that's not right because
the woman who claimed 50 never claimed
that she ever got fined I can set off
without doubt what she's claiming is
other women will find and their
percentage was much higher so that's not
right
she wouldn't know she would never no no
so she said this is the problem she's
sin I never got fined I got 50 because
you're trying to make it look like this
and this is what you're trying to
portray you're trying to portray this
point she got 50 then she got fined so
therefore the percentage reduced that's
basically what you're trying to explain
but what she said was no I got 50 she
never got fined all the women who
allegedly got a bigger percentage were
fined that's what it was that's not true
but I'm just curious how would she know
she got 50
sorry how would she know she got 50
percent well she said she got 50 I'm
asking you how she would know how would
she know if she didn't
uh I'm I'm going by Andrew Tate's
statements to figure out what was paid
or not and Andrew Tate himself has said
that he would try to scam the models but
I'm curious because no no no no no no no
no this is the problem you see because
you know again uh and another point is
this you know when you said you used the
bottom [__] method and you know he used
a woman to Lara and get another woman
there's no woman who's who's open till
now out of the victims whose information
we have no woman has claimed that that
occurred so no woman has said that
Andrew tear took her for dinner brought
her bottom [__] and then tried to
Allure her and convince her and then
make her go abroad no one has said that
they all have said that they all went
abroad based on their own interaction
with the tits and there was no other
woman involved in trying to Allure them
how many um do you know how many people
right now are um filed as injured
persons I think for the case yes eight
right seven are you sure I thought it
was six and then they added two more it
was six divided one more okay so it's
either seven or eight how many women
worked with him
what do you mean didn't he say at one
point that he had up to 75 women working
at one time that's what the website says
but again this is the problem so he did
say that and one can assume uh because
you're right he did say that I'm not
going to deny that he said that
basically I had 75 women working for me
and that we could get rich together he
did say that okay in terms of what the
core information says it doesn't say
anything related to that in terms of the
BC documentary they're trying to portray
the fact that it's actually a very small
operation and there was hardly any women
has the prosecution as many of you know
I was just banned on Tick Tock and we
are demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible